let's have a think about this situation
so you can't stand a deck of playing
cards okay now I elected because I
wanted to mostly use this whiteboard as
a whiteboard I elected not to stick up
an entire deck of playing cards on the
board because then I would have no board
to use but here you've got ace through
King I've just chosen spades because it
looks good and here I want you to
imagine each of these cards up on the
board representing all four cards of
that value does that make sense because
of course there's not just one ace in
the deck there are four aces it's not
just one Jack there are four jacks so
every one of those represents four how
many cards are there across the top
there are 13 here 13 in one suit and so
if each one represents the four of its
client in the in the deck then 4 times
13 52 is our sample space
okay 52 is our sample space so I said
before we wanted to develop your
intuition and then create some few
realities so now you can see I'm
introducing some notation you've already
seen like from calculus how powerful and
important notation can be so let's go
back to the way we used to do things in
stage 5 and talk about this event give
it a name right I mean call this
favorable event the 7/8 queen or ace
that's the thing I'm interested in I'm
gonna call it e4 event very original
name right so how would we write the
probability of this what would I write
yeah P the probability and then bracket
a there we go
done right so this feels a little bit
like function notation right similar
kind of idea right so what's the
probability of a well I want to figure
out the 7 there's the 7 which is a
different color there's the 7 right
there there's the 8 there's the queen or
should have done the ACE right at the
beginning we go so what I've got here is
how many times favorably right do these
events happen there each of these
representing 4 cards right so 4 times 4
that's 16 so I'm hoping you had a 16 on
the top of your fraction to begin with
that's the number of favorable words and
then you divide by the total sample
space which we already established is
very good that's it now we of course
can't simplify this because we know how
to deal with fractions for on 13 so
thumbs up to you
if you got that number but extra thumbs
up to you if you knew why that was the
number because of course just getting it
right is not actually the main thing
we're focused on it's having the
reasoning underneath this okay now let's
start thinking about the conditions
what does Part B says say it says you
know we're looking at the same event
right if it is known that we have a
picture card right they're really
dealing out well they're only selecting
one card right now let's have a look at
the picture cards over here here are the
picture cards the put more technical
name does anyone know what the technical
name for the picture cards is by the way
royalty the Royals also the court cards
are all the same thing right so when you
think about this we now know this is a
little bit like me opening my hand and
say oh look this is six here right we
know information about this we've
already established this changes the
sample size remember when I had my array
here right there were some things I
could just ignore 25 options I could
ignore okay warning
so in the same way I'm going to reduce
the sample size so if I say this is Part
B right I'm going to introduce some
notation here I'm going to say let's an
own piece of information right so for
knowing I'm going to call this K and you
can see later on I'm gonna have a few
different known events or rather just
call it k I'm gonna call it okay one
because I'm gonna have a K 2 and K 3 a
minute right let's call this sky you
know picture cards when we had a look at
the two dice we needed to know and we
use the diagram to do this right we need
to know what is the new sample size now
we actually have language for this right
we would say the size is n right n for
number and then we just put in will
whatever event you're interested in I
just gave it a name so I'm gonna say
what's the sample size now given that
I'm limiting myself to picture cards
okay have a look I've got three kinds of
picture cards each one on the board
represents four so what's the new sample
size twelve very good that is the number
in this set okay
it'll really help you look out this is
my new sample size I'm gonna use that in
a second now before remember we look at
the to see
right all we said was well there's still
one favorable of it that hasn't changed
and then I divide by my new sample size
one over eleven there's my probability
okay can someone tell me why I can't
simply do that in this situation I can't
just say I have a new sample size just
gonna put that on the bottom and then
there's my new probability anyone see
the big glaring problem if I say the
probability of this event which I'm
going to write in a second
right okay very good
and you both identified it my favorable
events before there was 16 of them right
16 how could you possibly say 16 over
this sample size you're like wow this is
like super probable to happen this is
clearly something's going wrong okay so
when we think about conditions we're not
just adjusting the sample space
we're also adjusting the favorable
events have a look up on the top of the
board right which favorable events can I
just ignore the ace the 7 and the 8 I
need to remove them from this right so
when I think about the probability of my
event happening okay and here's a bit of
new notation for you possibly we put a
long vertical bar we call it pipe
actually but anyway this vertical bar
means this event happening if you know
that this other thing is true okay so
that's the way I read this right what's
the probability of this event if you
know that this is some kind of knowledge
that you have it's a condition right
when I'm working this out it's not just
this sorry it's not just this sample
space that changes which is 12
it's also my favorable events I don't
have 16 of them anymore I've only got
the Queens that I can be interested in
how many Queens are there there are
there four of them right which in some
ways makes intuitive sense when you look
at that you're like oh of course that is
going to be one in three you can see
it's green / blue right one-third make
sense okay let's have a look at seed I'm
not going to hold your hand for this one
just yet I want you to think about how
we applied this logic how we changed two
things number one we changed the sample
space and then number two we change
the favorable events I want you to look
at Part C and see if you can work it out
on your own give you a minute or two to
have a think